Bitcoin possesses all the attributes not
only have good money but of supremely
good money replacing fiat currency with
fiat digital currency is not an
improvement if you want a market-based
system of money that doesn't get shut
down when it grows past the size of a
novelty it has to be decentralized
bitcoin is yeah it's divisible it's
portable ism you know it's all these
things but apart from the fact that it
can be utilized in transaction it's
nothing nothing has intrinsic value
intrinsic value is a meaningless term
because value has to be subjective in
the eyes of the valuer
the bottoms gonna drop out of the market
like all bubbles and everyone's gonna
want to sell there's gonna be no demand
it's gonna be massive supply the whole
thing is gonna implode welcome now to
the main event arguing for the
affirmative on the resolution we have
shapeshift CEO Erik Voorhees
Erik please come to the stage are caring
for the negative we have Euro Pacific
Capital CEO Peter Schiff Peter please
come to the stage
a very raucous crowd you gotta Peter
please I don't want you guys near each
other this is the Rutgers Cup I have to
sit between you and and as you know the
resolution yes pastor Jones well that's
very nice okay
you guys getting okay please the the
resolution as you know is Bitcoin or a
similar form of cryptocurrency will
eventually replace government's fiat
money as the preferred medium of
exchange Erik Voorhees please take the
podium and defend that resolution thank
you all right hello everyone my name is
Erik Voorhees I'm the founder and CEO of
shape-shift which is a leading digital
asset exchange it's available nearly
everywhere in the world other than here
in New York because New York is quietly
suffocating under a depressing pall of
statism the question of who's more
socialist in New York or China would
perhaps be a good topic for a SOHO
debate I'd like to thank Jean Epstein in
the forum for hosting the debate I would
also like to thank Peter for agreeing to
spar with me here this evening Peter is
someone that I've looked up to for a
very long time back in 2008 prior to
Bitcoin I listened to Peters podcasts
every day while driving to work much of
what I've learned about money and
economics came from him so Peter thank
you for all that you have taught me over
the years
and thank you especially for agreeing to
take the position of defending fiat
currency tonight for Lord knows that I
never would tonight I make the case that
Bitcoin or a similar form of
cryptocurrency will eventually replace
government fiat as the preferred means
of exchange I'll use the term Bitcoin
loosely here to refer to any such
cryptocurrency that accomplishes that
goal I'm going to construct the argument
in four pieces first why bitcoin is good
money
second why Fiat is bad money third why
gold or other forms of market-based
money are insufficient fourth why
bitcoin will win so first why is Bitcoin
good money as we all know mankind has
used many different things as money
money's come and go and the adoption of
one monetary standard over another is
the rule rather than the exception
throughout history but a society's
choice of money is not arbitrary there
are certain attributes of money which
seem preferable to others Gold scores
highly on these attributes which is why
it has remained an indelible monetary
standard for millennia to assess
bitcoins likelihood of assuming the
monetary throne for the next period of
human history one must first understand
its attributes first I'll point out the
Bitcoin possesses all the attributes not
only of good money but of supremely good
money it is not marginally better than
alternatives rather it is in its own
league entirely first Bitcoin is
provably scarce there are only 21
million of them and there can never be
more I can tell you exactly how many
there will be tomorrow the answer is 17
million 130,000 620 I can tell you the
supply a year from now and ten years
from now let's see any central bank
attempt such a feat and yet while scarce
bitcoin is easily divisible one Bitcoin
can be cut into 100 million pieces and
recombined at will in terms of
divisibility bitcoin wins hands down
over both fiat and gold bitcoin is also
durable a bitcoin exists as a ledger
entry backed up on thousands of
computers around the world certainly if
the internet went down you'd be unable
to use bitcoin but that is also true of
your credit cards PayPal banks in any
other form of modern money so bitcoin is
that no disadvantage to fiat in this
regard bitcoin is fungible each bitcoin
is worth the same as every other it is
recognizable every Bitcoin wallet can
quickly attest weather bitcoin is
legitimate
not a Bitcoin cannot be counterfeited
unlike with gold it cannot be filled
with tungsten and as one of its greatest
attributes bitcoin is highly portable
you can send it anywhere on earth for
very little cost it moves across borders
with ease it has no concept of borders
it has no weight it has no smell and has
no physical body that can be blocked or
apprehended indeed it is the only form
of money today which can be moved at
distance without trusting a third party
it is the only money that doesn't
require permission from an overseer
therefore it is the only money
appropriate for free people finally
bitcoin also possesses an important
attribute which will one day be seen as
critical for good money programmability
bitcoin can be programmed to enable all
kinds of economic activity often without
a middleman escrow agent or human
arbitration of any kind this program
ability without having to trust anyone
is impossible with fiat and in a digital
age will come to be one of its most
important advantages next let's discuss
why fiat is bad money
why should we care about
cryptocurrencies and their attributes
when we already have Fiat Fiat works
pretty well right
it's got pyramids and government
buildings printed on it so you know it's
valuable also it is backed by paper
paper can be burned if you're cold in
the winter there's its intrinsic value
try that with gold but a skeptical
observer should know that fiat money is
an absolute scam and something
altogether inappropriate for an ethical
market-based society as I like to say
you cannot have a free market when the
most important good money itself is
centrally planned and controlled fiat
money and a market economy are mutually
exclusive concepts like oil and water
they can certainly be mixed up together
when forest is applied but they will
naturally separate and dispel one
another over time indeed the average
lifespan of fiat is less than 50 years
the US dollar only became fiat in 1971
that's less than the length of William
Shatner's career and as it happens last
week he announced that he has started to
mind bitcoins as well
[Applause]
regardless when examining at specific
properties as money most ways Fiat is
unimpressive first is not scarce it is
systematically created out of thin air
with no limit on supply nor can supply
even be known Thea is willed into
existence by politicians and banks
because printing money enriches the
printer at the expense of the public who
holds the previously printed money the
phenomenon is known as inflation
inflation or currency debasement fiat
also struggles with durability your fiat
will only last so long as your bank
permits and even then it slowly loses
its value your bank can destroy your
fiat with the click of a button ask a
Cypriot ask an Argentinean how durable
Fiat is with fiat you were ever
dependent on a third party with your
wealth is that an attribute of money
that you find attractive some people are
comfortable with it because they trust
their government but requiring trust in
politicians seems a poor foundation upon
which to build a prosperous society
finally fiat is not nearly as portable
as bitcoin tried to send an
international wire right now you can't
because it's after 5 o'clock how quaint
is that you can try tomorrow morning as
long as it's not Sunday because
apparently God doesn't want you to use
the financial system on the Sabbath but
even when successful you'll discover it
takes 3 to 5 days for your wire to
arrive you often have to physically go
to the bank to do this you have to fill
out a form on paper while someone making
$15 an hour takes that info and types it
back into a computer why do people put
up with this nonsense
indeed it is faster to strache trap cash
to an anvil and FedEx it to Tokyo than
it is to send an international wire do
you really think that that system is
going to out-compete Bitcoin in an open
marketplace and you can only send Fiat
if you have permission try to send it to
a family member in Russia
you'll be censored wants to donate to
relief effort perhaps in Venezuela too
bad you'll be censored are you sending a
suspicious amount your payment will be
blocked and you better get ready for
questioning or outright confiscation yep
the Orwellian nanny state is alive and
well and fiat currency is one of its
most insidious tentacles fiat has these
poor monetary attributes because it is a
tool and appendage of the state it
exists to serve the state now
to exist market participants its
attributes as money are intentionally
constrained in inferior so as to siphon
wealth to the state through debasement
and to surveil and control the behavior
of the Kings subjects remember that Fiat
means value by decree not by merit so
why are gold and other alternatives
insufficient I love gold I own gold and
I would like to own more gold I
understand why gold is good money and
Peter has done a great job of teaching
such concepts to the public but gold as
a physical heavy commodity cannot be
efficiently used as money at scale
imagine trying to run payroll with
physical gold coins try to make change
for a pizza with bullion and forget
about payment at strip clubs bruisin
women is not cool unless you're the New
York Attorney General Schneiderman
[Music]
[Applause]
suffice to say that gold went in
physical form is impractical for
commerce for gold to work in a modern
economy it must be warehoused by a
company and then digital certificates or
credits must be issued against that gold
those digital certificates could
theoretically work well as money in a
moderate economy except for one problem
centralization a digital gold payment
service or any privately issued
market-based money requires some form of
centralized control or custody and thus
exposes users to counterparty risk this
is fatal because of such a private
company ever grows to scale the
government could shut it down unplug it
servers arrest his principal's and seize
its assets this exact thing happened
with the gold and another company gold
money was so scared of this happening
that they stopped allowing payments of
digital gold between customers entirely
private money when centralized probably
cannot attain scale and thus cannot
surpass Fiat because the government
won't allow it
so why will Bitcoin win the coin will
win because there is no competition in
money and Bitcoin is the best money
currently available because it's
decentralized it cannot be stopped it
doesn't happen all at once
nobody switches immediately from fiat
and banks to Bitcoin and blockchain
rather Bitcoin will simply gradually
come to be used as an occasional
alternative to fiat individuals will
find specific times and places in which
it is easier faster safer or cheaper
to use Bitcoin to store or transfer
wealth than to use credit cards or banks
indeed two billion people in the world
don't even have credit cards or banks
for them the choice will be easy yet
despite the failings of the legacy
system Bitcoin now imbues every human on
earth with financial sovereignty with
the coin anyone of any age race or creed
no matter which imaginary lines they
were born within and nothing more than a
$50 smartphone can send and receive
money anywhere in the world instantly at
near zero cost and there isn't a goddamn
thing that anyone else in the world can
do to stop that it is one of the most
potent tools of individual empowerment
ever invented and is happening right in
front of us fiat now persists solely on
the mentum of the momentum of tradition
the older generations may cling to it
for quite some time but they and their
ways are dying and their wealth decays
in front of them to baste openly by the
very people they worship salute and vote
into office someday schoolchildren will
laugh and joke with each other as they
learn about the silly flag paper with
cultish incantations inscribed on it
which in yet another of history's
examples of mass delusion people thought
to be valuable or maybe they won't laugh
and joke because they will have learned
how much destruction it actually caused
maybe fiat will be looked at more like
medieval bloodletting a dark symptom of
human ignorance that is so obviously
foolish in hindsight Fiat will fall in
time and in its place true decentralized
market-based money will emerge the
profit motive alone will lead capital
gradually away from those assets which
can be debased and censored to those
which cannot to future generations it
will appear as inevitable as the
collapse of serfdom and for the very
same reason this is why Bitcoin or some
other cryptocurrency will eventually
replace government feel
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You podium Peter authoring for
their negative taking away Peter Thank
You Jean for inviting me here
Soho forum reason I you know I've worked
with reason on the Occupy Wall Street
video that I did and Eric thanks for
dressing nicer than Max Keiser it was my
the last Bitcoin debate that I did you
know I wish you could have pervade
persuading me to buy Bitcoin a few years
ago but you know don't confuse the fact
that financially bitcoin has been a
success for a lot of people who happen
to get into it early with whether or not
it's ultimately going to succeed at
replacing the dollar or any other fiat
currency as as money and I'm not here to
defend the the fiat based monetary
system that exists today I agree with
Eric it is going to fail and I believe
occurrence in crisis is headed for us I
just don't believe that the future is
Bitcoin that Bitcoin is going to succeed
where the dollar or other fiat
currencies fail and to understand money
you have to understand its origins and
and and and what it's attempting to do I
mean before the dollar was a fiat
currency it was a legitimate currency
and what is a legitimate currency it's a
currency that's actually backed by real
money in the case of the dollar that
real money was gold gold backed the
dollar and what gave the dollar value
was the gold that backed it up so nobody
wanted dollars dollars were just a more
convenient way of transacting in gold
and you know before governments began
issuing currency private banks issued
currency backed by buy gold again the
private currency simply facilitated gold
transactions like you know I guess at
the strip club it's easier to put a bill
in a stripper than the coal point right
so it made it easier but but the
stripper is still earning the gold
that's what they wanted
and you know and then and then before
they had paper money they just had gold
coins write gold was you just you know
had gold coins and you know coins were
an improvement over just nuggets write
gold bullion why work wines better
because if the coin was made from a mint
that you recognized you knew exactly how
much gold was in that coin and why is
that important well because gold is a
commodity right and if you are
exchanging goods or services for gold
you want to know how much gold you're
getting because that's you know it's the
weight of gold that's important how much
gold am I getting for whatever it is
that that I am selling right and it and
before they had gold we had barter right
everybody just had a trade one product
for another product Gold money the
invention of money I made commerce much
more efficient and of course gold was
not the only money it wasn't the first
money but it was the best money and Eric
did an excellent job of going over a lot
of the characteristics that gold had
that made it more efficient as money
other than let's say cattle or wheat or
oil those are commodities but they they
don't work as well as money gold worked
beautifully as money which is why more
and more societies adopted it as money
and what bitcoin did very successfully
is it managed to replicate a lot of
those properties that gold had that made
it so successful as money in fact they
created Bitcoin to resemble gold right
if you look at a picture of Bitcoin not
that it actually exists but the way they
tried to you know presented it on a
piece of paper it's always the color of
gold it looks like a gold coin with a B
in the middle of it how do you create
bitcoins well you mind them I mean
there's no pictures there's no real
mining but they just called it my knee
because they wanted to make it sound
like you were creating digital gold
right but the reason that I have
referred to it as being fool's gold
is because bitcoin is replicating all of
the properties of gold except the most
important one
and that's the metal itself the element
the rare scarce element that has been
valued as a commodity for thousands of
years the reason people wanted gold as
money is because it was a luxury good
that people wanted if you didn't want it
yourself somebody else wanted it you can
do all sorts of things with gold other
than spend it right it's the actual uses
the physical properties and it's not
just the fact that gold is in jewelry
right that's the most important use but
gold is in all the cell phones that we
have they use it in aerospace they use
it in medicine I mean and there's a lot
of places that gold would be used but
they don't use it because they use other
metals instead that are less expensive
but if they could afford gold they would
use it because gold would do a better
job right the best teeth you want to get
a crown it's just there's gold in it if
you want to save money then you use
something else but if you want the best
you're gonna have gold in there and so
there's real value there on the other
hand Bitcoin is yeah it's divisible it's
portable it's and you know it's all
these things but apart from the fact
that it can be utilized in transaction
it's nothing it has no real value into
itself as a commodity there's no way to
relate the price of Bitcoin to the price
of anything else I mean you have
thousands of years of history to know
how much gold should be worth in terms
of oil or weed or any other commodity or
whatever you're doing but Bitcoin
there's no reference point it's only
existed for nine years
you know nobody it never had any value
other than as a medium of exchange there
is this supposed 21 million unit
scarcity which is a self-imposed
scarcity the only reason it's scarce is
because they created it to be scarce
except it's not scarce because Bitcoin
can be forked off as many times as you
want there's Bitcoin cash there's
Bitcoin gold whatever meanwhile there's
another 1,500 or so crypto currencies
that can do everything Bitcoin can do
some of them can do it better faster
cheaper there's no limit to the number
of other digital currencies that can be
created there's only one gold they'll
never be another gold yeah there are
other metals on the periodic table but
they're not gold they're not exactly the
same as gold but you can make as many
crypto currencies that are exactly the
same as Bitcoin they just have a
different name but they have the exact
same properties although they may have
better properties they may be cheaper or
faster but the biggest problem with
Bitcoin and why could never be used as
money is because one of the most
important functions of money is that it
has to be a reliable store of value not
just a medium of exchange Bitcoin can do
that although it's inefficient you know
and I think at its peak when Bitcoin
prices got up to 20,000 it was something
like 50 60 bucks just to spend one so
obviously you know you couldn't use it
to buy a cup of coffee if you know that
cost sixty dollars to buy the five
dollar coffee so we you know it isn't
that easy to use but you know maybe if
you're trying to buy a car big payment
but the problem with it is there is no
certainty as to its future value right
you have no idea what bitcoin is going
to be worth from hour to hour let alone
day to day or year to year in order for
something to be money you need to be
able to price products in it you need to
be able to negotiate contracts in it I
need to be able to borrow and lend in it
right I need to be able to buy insurance
in it none of these things can ever be
done with Bitcoin because nobody knows
what if anything it's going to be worth
in the future even Eric doesn't know
Eric you know it could be worth a
million or it could be worth nothing
that can't be money you can't have a
currency that has no reliable store
value no you could say well same thing
with fiat currency yeah fiat currencies
have lost value over time slowly and
eventually they made collapse but most
people who transact in dollars or Euros
are in have complete confidence in their
value they may acknowledge that they
will lose value slowly but they accept
that and you have all of the the history
of use you have the socially accepted I
mean you have prices everything is
denominated in these local currencies
and even if they're losing value slowly
they're losing value slow enough that
the market can still transact in it but
there is no way to transact in in in
Bitcoin
and if you don't like fiat currency and
you want to use something else it is
very easy to use gold I mean as Eric
said you can have a company like gold
money for example that has been you know
reinvented now more recently now that
Turk sold two-bit gold and they change
the name to gold money but you can have
gold on deposit and you can spend your
gold you could spent you can transfer it
very inexpensively to anybody who wants
to accept it you could break it down
into grams and you can buy a cup of
coffee with it for less money than it
would cost you to buy a cup of coffee
using your Bitcoin sure eric says well
you have to trust a third party well
people have been trusting third parties
with gold forever since Gold's been
money it worked fine in 19th century
America when people trusted third
parties with their gold
I mean Brinks is the third party that
holds your gold at gold money they've
never lost an ounce of gold since
they've been storing it and their entire
hundred some-odd your history now could
the government come in and maybe
confiscate their money well they haven't
done it before I mean in theory any
government can confiscate anything but
you know they have gold stored all
around the world I mean is every single
government you know is Switzerland is is
Hong Kong is Dubai is Australia or all
these government's gonna start seizing
gold from every depository
but the idea to think that governments
can't ban Bitcoin if they don't want to
you don't think governments can
criminalize the use of Bitcoin you don't
think they can take and tell the banks
that they regulate you can't do business
with anybody who's using Bitcoin you
can't exchange Bitcoin for any fiat
currencies they could put you in jail
they can you know they can make the
penalty 10 years 20 years in jail for
getting caught with a Bitcoin I mean
it's very easy for the government to
criminalize it if they want to do it I
mean I think they have more of a chance
of criminalizing that than they would of
owning gold so I think at the end I
agree with Eric completely that the Fiat
monetary system that we have now is not
going to work but replacing fiat
currency with fiat digital currency is
not an improvement right it is still a
fiat what gives
Bitcoin value the only thing that gives
it value is Khan
it's confidence that other people will
accept it in the future that's the same
thing that gives the dollar value or
that gives the Euro or the yen except
with the dollar you've got legal tender
you've got a whole banking system and a
society that's built around it and the
government requires every American
citizens to pay their taxes every year
and you have to pay it in dollars so if
you don't want to go to jail you have to
have dollars to pay your taxes
nobody has to have bitcoins for anything
right now people want bitcoins because
they think they're gonna get rich why do
they think they're gonna get rich
because they think the price is going to
go up because they believe that one day
it's gonna be money it's not money now
it's not being used as money now it's
being used as a speculative asset but
the speculation is that that's going to
change in the future and that one day
it'll be money but that is a promise on
which Bitcoin nor any other
cryptocurrency is ever capable of
delivering so ultimately if you want to
go to the future you've got to go to the
past the future of money is gold and if
gold is going to be digitized if we're
gonna have gold a gold back
cryptocurrency cryptocurrency backed by
real money just like the initial
banknotes used to be backed by real
money then that can succeed and that is
the only type of cryptocurrency that can
succeed but all of the crypto currencies
that exist today whatever 1500 of them
that are backed by nothing are no better
than the you know the national crypto
currencies that they're hoping to
replace thank you
we bottle from an appointee shop take
the podium alright
so Peter covered a lot of topics I will
try to remember most of the points that
he was making and address some of them
first of all I think we should cover for
a second this idea that that Bitcoin has
no intrinsic value this is a word this
intrinsic value that I think a lot of
Austrians have struggled with for quite
some time
nothing has intrinsic value intrinsic
value is a meaningless term because
value has to be subjective in the eyes
of the valuer something that you think
is intrinsically valuable for example
like water because all of us have to
drink it is only valuable if there's a
human there that's thirsty if there's a
human there that's not thirsty the water
is not valuable at all before humans
roamed the earth gold had zero value
whatsoever
there was no species or no sentient life
that thought that that mineral was
valuable to them so value is subjective
value comes when the person doing the
valuing finds a good reason or purpose
for that thing to use this is true of
gold this is true of Bitcoin second if
there is such a thing as intrinsic value
for the sake of argument bitcoins
intrinsic value in this sense comes from
its payment network and Satoshi did a
injustice I think to the system by
calling both the payment network itself
and the unit of account the currency
both have the name of Bitcoin the
payment network is the only way in the
world that you can send a transaction to
someone else in a decentralized way
where no one can stop it between any two
people on earth no border whatsoever
it cannot be censored and it is really
cheap to actually do it
if that isn't valuable then I don't I
don't know what is now you may say it's
not worth the price the bitcoins are
going for today and that would be a
valid argument
but to say that that system which was
the first in history to allow two people
at distance to transact with each other
is not valuable flies in the face of
reason second let's talk about
volatility for a second you are totally
right that bitcoins current volatility
would make it a very poor use of day to
day money today I will see that point
absolutely
but volatility is not an aspect of
Bitcoin which is intrinsic to it
in other words volatility is what
happens when the market is trying to
decide on its value Bitcoin is new it is
small over time it will achieve
stability just as it has when I got
involved in 2011 it would move 50
percent in a day today it's a big deal
when it moves 10 percent and I think 10
years from now it'll be a big deal when
it moves 2 or 3 percent
stability as a market asset is earned
with time you cannot design something to
be stable so while bitcoin is definitely
too volatile today I think that problem
is is self-correcting next I want to
address the multiple coins as inflation
argument which is that bitcoins not
really scarce because there's a there's
all sorts of coins that can be
replicated from it
just as gold is scarce and I can't make
the claim that there are other metals
and thus gold is not scarce I don't
think that you can make the claim that
just because there are other kryptos
that big that means bitcoin is not
scarce you can copy the code but the
code is not the network you cannot copy
the hash power of the miners you cannot
copy the infrastructure of all the
wallets and all the companies that
operate on the Bitcoin network you
cannot copy the the brand actually you
cannot copy that reputation that Bitcoin
has earned in time and we don't need to
debate this on a theoretical level we
have actually seen this happening so
when we last debated Peter a few years
ago and make 2013 there was about 10
billion dollars as the entire market cap
of Bitcoin and all the alts everything
other than Bitcoin
put together it was about 1 billion
dollars according to your theory if more
blockchains happened and more alts came
out and more money even went into those
alts the market cap of Bitcoin itself
should decline yet what we've seen is
that alts have exploded they're now a
hundred and fifty billion dollars in
value and Bitcoin also has increased in
value it's now a hundred and ten billion
dollars in market cap so if it was true
that more coins and blockchains would
debase the value of Bitcoin the market
cap of Bitcoin should be far less than
it is today and this doesn't have to be
a mystery to anyone a clone of bitcoins
code is not a clone of Bitcoin and then
the last thing so you I think are
suggesting again that gold is really the
way to have a modern society based on
honest money I would absolutely prefer
that the world use gold then to use Fiat
and I again I'm a big fan of gold and I
understand why it's valuable and why
it's useful but the point remains that
it is not practical for commerce unless
you are trusting of some counterparty
and you of all people Peter know that
governments will not allow something to
compete with their formal value if they
can stop it so if you want a
market-based system of money that
doesn't get shut down when it grows past
the size of a novelty it has to be
decentralized it cannot have an
individual person or company or vault
that can be seized if that's what you
have then you will never actually have a
free market financial system because the
government simply will not allow it gold
indeed was confiscated in the 30s this
is not some crazy idea and even though
gold works very well in 19th century
America people weren't doing online
commerce in 19th century America the
world has changed to some degree it
doesn't mean that the principles of
money have changed but it does mean that
the form of money in today's economy
that works the best may have changed so
with that all Aleta
all right a couple a couple of points
first of all let me try to go backwards
as far as the the argument of government
shutting down a competition we know they
do this right I mean you know they don't
let people compete with the post office
but they allowed Federal Express and you
know a lot of you know uber hasn't been
shut down I mean that competes with
government monopolies on taxicabs so you
know I don't think that governors are
gonna be too quick to shut down people
transacting in gold I do think that
they're more likely to crack down on
Bitcoin as I said before and I think
it's easier I mean there's not that much
anonymity and I mean I've heard now that
it's almost like a fingerprint if you
you know criminals are using Bitcoin to
launder money now all of a sudden you
know it's actually a record of the
transactions the government's can go
into the computers and kind of figure
out you know where these transactions
took place I mean if if I just hand gold
to somebody I mean it's like handy cash
so I think ultimately if the
government's gonna try to put a stop to
anything it they're more likely to put a
stop to crypto currencies I think one of
the reasons they're not doing it is
because I think they pretty much
realized they're gonna fail as far as
the argument about the market cap and I
acknowledged early on I wish I'd have
listened to you earlier and bought some
Bitcoin the price of anything is a
function of supply and demand and even
though the supply of crypto currencies
has exploded massive inflation the
demand has grown even faster and so as
long as demand is rising faster than
supply price can go up the problem is
what happens when all the demand goes
away so you said earlier that you know
exactly what the supply of Bitcoin is
gonna be later next year next week
whatever may be fine but you know what
the demand is gonna be there may be no
demand I believe that the majority of
the demand is coming from speculators
who are buying it because they want to
sell it to somebody else everybody who's
buying Bitcoin ultimately wants to sell
it
to buy something real nobody wants a
Bitcoin right they want what they can
buy when they sell their Bitcoin but no
one wants to sell it now everybody's
holding on or coddling me because it's
going to a million right so nobody wants
to sell no one wants to be the idiot
that gets out but at some point the
bottom is gonna drop
market like all bubbles and everyone's
gonna want to sell there's gonna be no
demand it's gonna be massive supply the
whole thing is going to implode which
gets down to the concept of intrinsic
value and I disagree that it's
impossible to have intrinsic value and
when I'm talking about intrinsic value
what I'm referring to is what you can do
with the money
absent its utilization as a medium of
exchange or store value right there are
things that I can do with gold right
there are actual things that you can do
with it that you can't use other metals
because they're not a good substitute
because they don't share the properties
of gold
Gold is very unique among metals and
there are a lot of things that you can
do with it I mean obviously - I mean if
you use catalyst money yeah you can eat
the cattle right I mean you get you know
there are things you could do with it
but there is nothing you can do with
your Bitcoin that is the point on the
lack of intrinsic value if I don't have
somebody who wants it there is
absolutely no actual demand for it there
is real demand for gold that always will
exist absent it's it's functioning as
money and so that gives it a real floor
there's actual some tangible use sure I
mean there's this big network of people
that accept Bitcoin so what I mean how
many people have myspace accounts right
that was a network Facebook came along
oh it was better I mean what's the odds
think about all the technologies that we
have today you know does anybody have
the first cell phone ever made anyone
have the first camera the first
television the first automobile oh all
right someone comes up with a better one
so what's the odds that Bitcoin is the
best cryptocurrency that's ever gonna be
invented you know and so if it can be
easily replaced by something that's
better because you know if you if you
look at what what you can do with it
well I could do the same thing with any
other cryptocurrency but the problem is
even if there's a cryptocurrency now
that's better than Bitcoin and there
probably are many there are other ones
that have yet to be devised that will be
better than those and so the problem is
you can't use it as money you can't
store it just like I you know I couldn't
use the first cell phone as money or I
couldn't use the first you know
all these products are losing value in
the market as somebody comes up with
something better to replace it right
gold nobody's come up with a better goal
that thousands of years people you know
people tried to make gold and they've
succeeded alchemists you know so we know
that's real money right but these crypto
currencies without any real value now I
say well you can make the arguable Peter
the dollar has no intrinsic value it
doesn't that's right but what it has is
the power of the state and it has the
history of use I mean the fact that it
used to be backed by gold and now it's
not I mean the government's watered down
our monetary system gradually over time
so we started with all this trust
because we weren't just trusting
anything because the paper money was
backed by gold but slowly the government
went off the gold standard and debased
our money and the dollars been losing
value steadily and slowly over the last
hundred years I mean eventually it's
gonna collapse and you know it'll go
away
but it's a slow process but I think
bitcoin and all these crypto currencies
it's gonna be a big process because
again right now let's say the top was
20,000 I think there's a good chance
that the market stopped out now how long
is it gonna take before the zeros out I
don't know there's a lot of trading
going on people are buying and selling I
don't think there's any real
capitulation yet I don't think any of
the long-term Bitcoin holders are scared
that Bitcoin went down 70% especially if
they've been in it for a long time but
there's a big difference between when
your market cap is as high as it is now
and you have a 70% drop then when it
went from $1 to 30 cents you know when
people lost their lunch money now you
got people with their IRA money you got
people with big amounts of money in in
Bitcoin that got suckered into this
mania between 10,000 and 20,000 and I
think that yeah right now bitcoins got a
lot going for it because you got all
these kids that are now you know
millionaires driving their their Lambos
right and everybody else has to tune out
all the fun right you know you know you
know you don't want to you know because
they're afraid of missing out all the
foam all right they know and but once
once the market
Crash's and you get the horror stories
of people that mortgage their house and
took out credit card loans to buy
Bitcoin and now they lost their life
savings right all of a sudden all the
stories of instant riches are gonna be
replaced by stories of big losses and
now the brand is tarnished and now
you've destroyed like a lot of these
people that bought Bitcoin at ten
fifteen thousand when they sell out at a
loss they ain't coming back right that's
gonna be so you destroy your market you
destroy the brand and all this demand is
gone and all you've got left is the
supply not just to supply bitcoins but
all the altcoins
that were created during the mania and
all that now investment that built up in
industries to cultivate to it it's all
gonna come crashing down just like every
other bubble
thank you guys we're now going to the QA
part of the evening Don Smith a big
Bitcoin bear do you have the first
question to ask
take it away Don Oh guys it was a good
debate I just I want to just stop to
point out I looked at the definition of
a fiat currency it's a currency that's
not backed by anything tangible in a
commodity currency is a currency that's
backed by something tangible or a
commodity so I think it's kind of funny
that we're debating how bad a fiat
currency is when Bitcoin by definition
is a fiat currency the other thing I
would point out so by definition you
have to vote no on the on the debate I
also point out that you know you can't
really buy anything with a Fiat with
Bitcoin right now to speak of I mean
there's a few places but you know and
people talk about hiding money or
avoiding taxes well anytime you want to
buy something you still gotta run it
through a bank I mean when you sell your
Bitcoin where you
have the cash sent - it's got to go to a
bank somewhere so I don't think it's a
very effective way of hiding money or I
don't even know why criminals would use
it because I don't they have to run
through a bank so maybe you can explain
that to me the other I'd like to tell a
story I have a friend who his wife came
in and he said honey I didn't want to
tell you this but about seven years ago
I took all the money of our piggy bank
and I bought Bitcoin and he said really
he says yeah and just hit 19,000 and we
want the good news the good news is
we're worth 70 million dollars and he
couldn't believe it she said the bad
news is I don't know where the code is
to get the money and I don't and to this
day I keep asking him did you ever find
the code and he hasn't found it it's a
long story John right that's a true
story
yeah yeah and so I want to know weird
that 70 million dollars ago I mean who
got it and the other thing is yeah how
do you what's that how do you you know a
Bitcoin does take a lot to manufacture I
mean you gotta buy semiconductor parts
you gotta use a lot electricity so you
can spend a lot of money to create
wealth
except when you're done there's nothing
tangible so you you spend money to get
it okay so John you had some very good
questions with all due respect I want to
make one point on the resolution reads
that Bitcoin will eventually replace
government's fiat money that's the
wording of the resolution so its
government's fiat money we're talking
about in this particular case for what
that's what thank you for your questions
done I think most of these shall look
you loved on okay Peter well most of
these questions are challenges Terrence
Eric you get first responders good
testing testing okay so regarding your
friend that's that's really tragic I
mean if you want to know where that
money went it went to buy us all of our
Lambos
actually in reality the freedom that
people actually get in the sovereignty
over their money that they get with
crypto comes with responsibility losing
that code was that person's
responsibility and it really sucks but
this is why it's important to educate
people on how to use Bitcoin instead of
getting distracted by things like the
price second you mentioned you mentioned
your definition of fiat being something
that's not backed by a commodity I
wonder if you get your definition of
inflation also from that same dictionary
because I'm guessing that it's wrong
Fiat actually means value by decree it
comes from anything that is valuable in
a marketplace because some legal reason
causes it to be valuable dollars are
fiat now when dollars were backed by
gold they were not Fiat bitcoins value
even if you think it is the most
speculative and stupid investment in the
universe that value does not come from
any decree it comes from its
desirability in an open marketplace
Bitcoin is absolutely not fiat next you
say that bitcoins not back to anything
that's because Bitcoin itself is a
commodity gold is also not backed by
anything it itself is a commodity that
people will find useful for one thing or
another
Bitcoin well is the same and people find
it useful for one thing or another so I
think I addressed your main points on
that yeah yeah my couple of points on it
when it comes to fiat money I mean what
what bitcoin has in common with fiat is
even though a government didn't decree
it as money there's no law that requires
anybody to accept it what stands behind
it is confidence in faith that you you
certainly share a lot of confidence in
faith in in Bitcoin and its future but I
would argue that as a raw commodity it
has no actual utility which brings me to
a good point that I didn't get a chance
to raise and that is the incredible
amount of resources in the form of
energy that is required to create a
Bitcoin I mean one of the arguments that
people can have against a gold standard
is that look at how
expensive it is to get gold out of the
ground and then if we're just gonna
stick it in another hole in the ground
and no one's gonna see it or use it you
know it's an expensive way to run the
monetary system now I think those costs
are small compared to the benefits of
having sound money versus all the losses
imposed by the Fiat system but if you're
gonna go to a cryptocurrency at least
find one that doesn't cost anything to
create I mean will I have to spend it
actually cost more might a might a
Bitcoin then an ounce of gold and at
least if I take that ounce of gold out
of a vault there is real value there
there's something I can do with that
gold I didn't waste all the resources
mining it out of the earth but the
Bitcoin once this Bitcoin bubble pops
all the electricity that was used to
create those bitcoins it was a complete
waste we didn't get anything of value
from all those those valuable resources
that were expended you know and but you
mentioned William Shatner you know what
William Shatner's do he's got a power
plant and what he's doing is selling the
power to the Bitcoin miners he's not
mining himself he's just selling these
guys power so that they can keep on
making bitcoins but you know eventually
it's you know the whole thing crashes
and you know it's no one's gonna mind a
Bitcoin if it costs you know whatever
six thousand of mine one and they're
only selling for a thousand bucks or
five hundred bucks then I guess the
mining just sit down until the cost
comes down doctor Canada I want to tell
the audience that for a very special
reason that resolution says it will
eventually replace governments fiat
money now now Erica isn't playing that's
a redundancy so to speak but I meant to
put that word in precisely to finesse
this issue the fiat money its
governments fiat money so that you are
still voting on a robust resolution I
will press government's very money but a
moderators Proctor to ask you a question
Peter
the the argument is about the value of
gold is that first it trades as a
monetary metal just as Bitcoin trades as
a monetary currency but second in the
case of gold if it no longer traded as a
monetary metal if there was no demand
for it as such it would collapse in
price
because its value as an ornamental
industrial metal is quite limited so
that 90 percent of the reason for the
gold for gold price is exactly the same
as the reason for bitcoins price would
you respond to that well I would
disagree I mean first of all I don't
know how you can ascertain that 90% of
Gold's value comes from its uses money
when hardly anybody uses it as money
today trace is a precious monetary metal
it responds our trade that's the
argument well but that's not what it's
being utilized for today I bet that's
how its price great no that's how
Italy's I don't know how its traded its
traded just Peterson oh no you don't
know what a scandal if that in mind if
somebody doesn't know if somebody is
buying gold you don't know but you have
a lot of Industry people in there that
are in the gold market trading but I
would say that if gold was priced as
money right now it would be priced a lot
higher than 12/5 any sales people might
be $10,000 an ounce right now gold is
basically price for jewelry it's not
priced as money it's not being
circulated as money it's not being safe
central banks have some goal but they
probably have less goal now than they've
ever had in their history so I don't
think there's much of a monetary premium
currently built into the price of gold
Peter just made a fascinating statement
about gold we might have a debate about
that Peter gold trade just jewelry trust
in strangers a commodity yeah does not B
doesn't it is an ostrich battle it's not
being rated right now as money we have
extended people are you know portfolio
managers aren't buying it as insurance
nobody owns gold right if they have
wanted surance they use derivatives or
they use something else okay you may be
said but one final question for the
moderator for my miners Barack anything
else having to do with with the degree
to which the government can enforce its
will with respect to gold or respect to
Bitcoin the question for Eric is
especially Peter said that despite the
fact that I think he sort of concedes
the government can seize gold it did it
did under Roosevelt gold was unlawful to
own and of course obviously it's
difficult to hide gold whatever it is
obviously a physical commodity much more
but on the other hand Peter said well
but they can say to banks everybody look
you could get caught trading Bitcoin 20
years in prison what about that
yeah well the government could
absolutely outlaw Bitcoin yeah yeah well
more easily because there would be fewer
people that would resist that today a
lot of people still think that bitcoin
is just used by criminals because that's
what the media likes to tell them I
guess I would bring up a few points on
that one is that governments have a
super poor record of successfully
banning anything they can write on paper
that you're not supposed to use it I'm
not aware of any time in history where
that actually works murder itself is
banned by the government and yet people
get killed all the time gold versus
Bitcoin Peter said that it's easier in
fact for the government to outlaw
Bitcoin use as money gold use I I agree
with that it is easier to ban it is
easier to ban Bitcoin than it would be
to ban gold because of popular sentiment
and force however
it would be harder to enforce it that's
the case if you have ten million dollars
and you want to move it somewhere on
earth if it is outlawed that gold is
probably not going to move or if it does
it's going to be a black market
transaction that requires a huge amount
of expense in order to do that just as
it would to get drugs across the border
I can I can send a billion dollars of
Bitcoin anywhere in the world without
anyone knowing about it yeah but the
problem possibility is but the problem
is if it's illegal no bank is ever going
to convert it into a currency so the
person you send it to is gonna have to
keep it and only give it to somebody
else who wants the Bitcoin but then of
course since you're doing this all over
computers you know governments are gonna
be able to track it down figure out what
address what computer figure the wallets
out and they can come and they can catch
people I mean I think it's harder if
somebody physically hands somebody a
gold coin unless the government is
physically you know following you around
that transaction is more in secret than
something that's done over a computer
network where government agents can be
monitoring the transactions and trying
to figure out you know what's
and so I you know I think it will be
easier to ban Bitcoin but I want to s
mention one question on your goalie gene
part up you know it costs I mean the
average mind-to-mind announce the goal
now is I don't know 1200 bucks why but I
mean it's expensive to mine gold so if
you thought gold was only worth $100 an
ounce nobody would be mining it and so
the only gold we would have to make
anything it would be the existing gold
what's and the price would have to go
way off unless everybody was gonna melt
down their jewelry if you wanted to make
new jewelry there'd be no new gold
coming because nobody would mind
especially since the government is
sitting on a billion ounces but so that
the point is there is some natural floor
know you know we talk about the cost of
mining Bitcoin that's nothing than the
cost there is a real physical cost to
extracting gold from the ground and that
also creates a base value for the metal
because you know you just can't get it
for free well how many people how many
how much gold is hold but held by
investors and speculators just as just
physical gold held by investors and
speculators I don't know the quantity
but it's it's very small small compared
to what they hold in stocks and bonds
stuff like that teeny compared to the
gold supply the above-ground gold supply
how much is it that I don't know the
exact okay you know yes I do it's an
immense but how is that much what a
charted the entire goal supplies
two-thirds is not being held by
investors would jump in they would dump
it all dump it all on the market but
what a people would have all the big
whales dump their Bitcoin how many how
many what what percentage of Bitcoin is
owned by the top hundred wallets I was
owning how many of those wallets are
owned by the same guy
I was only trying to address your issue
of intrinsic value of gold it it's it
could be valued as a monitor as an as a
metal that you put in your teeth or the
ornamental but that's that's far less
than its price I'm surprised that you
think the price of gold only responds to
jewelry demand a lot of people disappear
today there's very little investor
demand for gold I know I sell it you
know sales are down like 80 percent no
one wants gold right now Peter is in a
bad way with his business
big boys put me out of business he's
getting $2,000 honorarium tonight so
that's gonna keep the wolf from my app
yeah I'll take it
oh okay okay he's a happy man now he
didn't know that okay normally you got a
question so just letting you know I've
sent you a bunch of online questions
what's your question um my question is
for both of you actually
now Peter would you be willing to take a
Bitcoin versus gold bet with Erik
Voorhees here tonight I mean I think
he's already betting on it and I'm
betting against it so I don't know what
the point would be in the bed put your
money where your mouth is what bet did
you have in mind
yeah just uh you guys could figure out
the details yourself that essentially
you would be shorting Bitcoin and maybe
you would exchange the value like if
you'd for say that in the future gold is
gonna be worth less than the comparative
prices between Bitcoin and gold at the
moment then you would owe each other the
opposite whenever the bet ends I don't
know it's hard to agree on the exact
terms because Bitcoin could go up before
it goes down I mean I have no idea what
no I ever get throw it out there I've
got a simple a simple arbitrage of you
you go long Bitcoin and short gold a
Peter goes long gold and short Bitcoin
and in in in 12 months we've pony up
well that's a tough bed I mean yeah
Bitcoin get double any moment you know
they collapse to zero all right John
John Smith will take but the list for
the time period the more certain I am
that I'm right 36 months okay no this is
one of those like classic Julian Simon
pow how about [ __ ] how about five years
how about five years Peter buddy
okay sixty months from now we're going
to me we're gonna send the prices it's a
simple trade and you can put a pop
you're gonna put up your entire
honorarium $2,000 we're gonna arrange
something very good suggestion Naomi
we're gonna work something out later
next question hi so much of both your
discussion has been about whether a
Bitcoin should or should not succeed in
this idea my question is what would it
take you to become convinced of the
opposite of your view in terms of for
Eric Bitcoin will not succeed not should
not will not Peter Bitcoin will succeed
not shouldn't sorry yeah it shouldn't
succeed it's a great question basically
what would it take for me to change my
opinion that Bitcoin or some other
cryptocurrency wouldn't place Fiat if
something better than cryptocurrency
happened right like something that
didn't use blockchains at all but
something that hasn't been invented yet
that came along that seemed to be
objectively better as a form of money
that could do it or if I think there was
a five to ten year period where at the
entire crypto market just slowly
dwindled toward zero I would have to
like assess during that time what was
the reasons for that but that might make
me change my opinion short of that you
know these little bubbles that go up and
down every few years they don't they
don't bother me at all ya know I think
it's interesting too though arrogant
people acknowledge that cryptocurrency
might ultimately succeed but it may not
be Bitcoin and maybe some other
cryptocurrency totally in which case
Bitcoin would be worthless yes totally
yes it and and for that very reason I
don't think any cryptocurrency will ever
succeed because I think if something can
replace Bitcoin then something will
replace what replaces Bitcoin look I
mentioned earlier that Facebook replaced
myspace in two years Facebook will
probably still be pretty big but judging
by the fact that a lot of younger people
don't use it anymore
in 20 years nobody might use it nobody
knows right what's gonna come up and so
Facebook shares maybe they're a good
speculation but you're not gonna use it
as money and and as far as what could
convince me since I don't share your
faith that the volatility will ever go
away see Eric believes that at some
point time even though bitcoin is too
volatile today to be money that at some
point in the future it won't be volatile
I just can't make that leap of faith
that the volatility is ever gonna go
away I can't see that point and I do
think that if all the people who are
holding Bitcoin ever got to the point
where they actually thought it had
topped out and was gonna be stable then
they'd want to cash out now they'd want
to start but you got all these people
living in their parents basements that
are mik Bitcoin millionaires and they
have nothing because they're afraid to
sell because they don't want to miss out
oh yeah yeah so I just can't in my mind
see how it can ever stop going up or
stabilized without collapsing as
everybody tries to catch up yeah okay we
need to get rid of this word faith here
okay the reason the people that are in
crypto are in crypto is not because of
faith it's because they've actually used
it and they've seen it work they've read
the code they understand what it's doing
it is an assessment of a technology
based on people's opinions of that
technology working and using it some
people I think a lot of people just own
it because it's gone up and they think
they're gonna get rich you can equally
apply that to gold especially after the
funny about that many people think
they're gonna get rich in gold not
anymore but that and that's why you
should be buying it you don't buy what
everybody else is fine look both both
crypto and gold have a large degree of
spective froth around them right there
are there are some gold speculators yes
is it frothy absolutely not the froth is
not in gold right there's a lot of froth
in a lot of assets these days whether
it's stocks or bonds or crypto
currencies but believe me there's no
frothing gold no I so I agree with that
right now there's not a lot of froth and
gold right now but there have been
bubbles in gold just as there are
bubbles in crypto and I don't think it's
not as big but yes there have been
periods of time I think we're golden God
overvalued you know 1980 when it had
gone up from $35 an ounce of
- 850 it was you know too high and it
pulled back went into a long-term bear
market but not to the extent the bubble
that I think we've seen in crypto
currencies I think is unparalleled I
mean I think this is you know when they
write the history books and about
bubbles that you know you have that
popular delusions of madness of crowds I
mean crypto currencies doesn't even need
to be a chapter it could be its own book
and you know I think even if Bitcoin
topped out at 20 thousand it's still
maybe the whole crypto thing might still
be the biggest bubble we've ever seen
but it is possible that Bitcoin can make
a new high I'm not smart enough to know
so the bubble could in fact get even
bigger if we if we looked at the price
of Apple's shares from the creation of
that company up to today it will have
gone through bubbles and it will be a
stratospheric Heights compared to what
it what it was back then
bubbles boy our markets but why why is
Apple's shares not a huge speculative
bubble that will crash to zero but
bitcoin is well they differ between a
speculative bubble and just being
overpriced right I mean you can
certainly make an argument that Apple is
expensive not based on its current price
multiple based on that Apple is
relatively inexpensive but the question
is can it maintain its dominance can it
maintain its market share in a free
market where everybody is gunning for it
everybody's trying to outdo it and make
a better product right build a better
mousetrap
what is the odds that Apple can continue
to innovate at the rate of the past and
the future and that its market cap will
continue to grow eventually no it's
going to it's going to fall the price is
gonna drop but Apple it when you buy
stock and Apple you're buying into a
company you're buying into a revenue
stream you're buying all the physical
and tangible assets in goodwill the
company you get the dividend you get you
know but when you buy Bitcoin you're not
buying into anything other than the
height and that the potential that
somebody else is gonna pay a higher
price right the whole bubble mentality
is the greater fool I'm gonna buy it
because some greater fool is gonna pay
me more and that fool is gonna buy it
because he's expecting a greater fool to
outbid him we're gonna see you run out
of fools and you're the last fool and
that's it that's great okay we have
Peter a question question from our vast
livestream audience this one in that
picks up on the
by the hypothetical the technology of
gold mining be let's say that gold does
get recognized more and more as money
and it expands its price doubles triples
whatever are you saying that for all
time
you know this intrinsic notion of yours
that gold is always going to be
expensive can they start mining from
asteroids I've been told by some gold
experts there's more gold in the ocean
than we've ever mined in the history of
the world if technology takes off and we
can suddenly double and triple the gold
supply inside of a few months oh well
what will that do to gold well in terms
of its scarcity the gold supply has been
growing you know for thousands of years
what if there's a technological leap
asteroids then we've had technological
leaps you know we've already obviously
mind that the cheap gold but look is
there gold in asteroids probably in
there I doubt the ocean yeah well I
don't know I mean maybe there's a lot of
stuff in the ocean I don't know what's
down there it's more Khoisan there's
more game in the ocean there's anywhere
else you know go to the ocean and try to
get it but okay I mean maybe look maybe
there's a way the co knows what it's
gonna cost as I started to say maybe
there's gold in asteroids I doubt
there's a an asteroid that's solid gold
I mean gold is very rare on earth it's
probably rare all over the universe and
so if there's an asteroid that has some
gold there's probably not a lot of it
but believe me if they're gonna mine
gold and asteroids the price is gonna be
sky-eye because they're gonna have to
mine every last bit of gold on earth
before someone takes a spaceship up to
an asteroid and tries to mine the gold
up there and then bring it back down to
earth I mean that's gonna be some
expensive gold and there is an immense
amount of gold in the ocean just but
yeah yeah yeah yes thank you so much
just gene quickly another great debate
Peter
awesome socks I really love them okay
just a quick question for Eric I have a
co-worker who prays at the altar of
Bitcoin and asked him a basic question
and I don't think he answered it
adequately so I'll ask you you might
have touched on something that this
could be
but potentially what do you think is the
main obstacle that can impede the growth
or the health of Bitcoin well in
bitcoins early years the major obstacle
impeding its growth was actually all the
libertarians they couldn't see a good
thing when it hit him
I think that's finally becoming a
non-issue anymore Bitcoin has grown much
larger than the libertarian community
around the world and I think at this
point the biggest impediment to its
adoption is simply that most individuals
still want governments to manage money
for them until that changes Bitcoin I
think will always be playing second
fiddle but I bet on Bitcoin largely
because I know that the history of money
is full of governments losing control
over their Fiats and there has never
been a financial crisis in which
cryptocurrency actually existed the next
time that happens I know where a lot of
the people are going to be going and so
that's what I'm waiting for yeah I think
it's very interesting you know that you
know the LOB viously the libertarian
community other than maybe criminals
were the first to embrace Bitcoin but
what's interesting is all of the
properties that the libertarians found
so appealing have actually been lost in
the effort to you know bring more people
into the into the bubble and and
mainstream it for the institutional
investors all the regulation the
government getting involved I mean now
you want to open up an account all the
KYC of a bank account they need your
passport they need your your driver's
license the utility bill you know the
transaction costs have gone up the
government oversight is it's not now
this thing that you're operating
underneath the radar right you're free
from the banking system and the and and
the Big Brother watching your
transactions and gone are the days where
it costs next to nothing to transfer you
know the big point because the
transaction costs have gone up so I
think Bitcoin has lost a lot of that
appeal in order to get the hedge funds
involved and the big money in and I
think that I mean this is great for the
libertarians who got in early and now
they have you know somebody to sell to
they have a need they can cash out but
if they actually stop and think
what bitcoin has become is not what they
originally embraced it's something
entirely different it's what they argued
against so totally disagree with that
Bitcoin bitcoin has absolutely grown and
many more people are involved now than
than they used to be and a much higher
portion of those people are no longer
libertarian types and that's okay that's
kind of all part of the plan to say that
bitcoin has lost its properties that
made it useful in the beginning is
simply not really hold on kind of
attracted the libertarian hold on to it
now it's all the greed and all yeah I'm
gonna get rich okay that has happened
both in gold and crypto so I don't think
that that's that's any different there
there is no government in the world that
knows how many bitcoins I have that was
true in 2011 and it's true today and
it'll be true 10 years for now but gold
gold has never been about getting rich
gold is about not becoming poor right
gold is about preserving weight no gold
is about preserving wealth it's a it's a
store of value it is not a
get-rich-quick scheme
people are not buying Bitcoin today to
store anything or preserve anything
people are buying Bitcoin because they
think the price is going to go up so
they're trying to accumulate wealth by
owning Bitcoin people buy gold in order
to preserve the wealth they've already
accumulated okay are you saying that
there's not a single person that owns
Bitcoin that did it for anything other
than speculative fervor no I'm saying
initially a lot of people got in for all
sorts of reasons but I would say that
most of the people who have bought
Bitcoin in the last six months through
year most of those people were motivated
solely by profit gold has never never
been about getting rich okay but that
question okay okay fair enough
okay it's only what we saw in Deadwood
okay I agree that but but but the
question okay I'm sorry a big final push
could you finally address this question
about emptyness challenge the scarcity
of Bitcoin he said there's all there's
all these Forks having to do with
Bitcoin so it is Bitcoin only 21 million
ounces always Peter right do with all
those Forks and whatever there's a lot
more than 21 million going to and be
involved
there's only 21 million bitcoins there
can never be more than but what about
the forks the boys like a lot bitcoin
just as silver is not gold just as iron
is not gold like coin - ammonia or not
bitcoin okay unfortunately there's no
real difference they all the same
property and there's a big difference in
gold and silver actually incorrect okay
okay
unfortunately what can I do it alright
well if I was on it if I was on a desert
island with my light coin what could I
do with it that I can't do with my
Bitcoin you can do about as much as you
could do with gold on a desert oh I can
do a lot with gold on a desert island
okay I can I can melt it into a bowl the
old economist truckers by 5 I can match
something with it you know time for that
kind of his joke assume we have a can
opener the economist on earth but that
aside guys you were great uh and you are
can now finally be able to give the
final passing in the five minute of
summation and so Peter as the negative
you go last and eric has five minutes to
sum up take it away all right this has
been fun
so I first learned about Bitcoin in 2011
I fell in love with it both as a
fascinating economic experiment and is
one of the greatest tools ever invented
for the advancement of human Liberty I
wrote an article in May of 2011 called
the separation called Bitcoin in the
separation of money and state in that
article I asked why are bitcoins
valuable and I answered by saying that
they simply possessed those attributes
of money that are most desired Bitcoin
was three dollars and almost nobody knew
about it or cared about it a year later
I wrote another article called Bitcoin
the libertarian introduction this
article pointed out that if a
marketplace tends to choose the medium
of exchange which best works as money
and bitcoins specific attributes make it
excellent money then perhaps the
marketplace will over time increasingly
use it for such by then Bitcoin had
written over a hundred percent to seven
dollars a year later in May of 2013 I
gave a speech at the San Jose Bitcoin
conference called the role of Bitcoin is
money
once again I argued that bitcoins
properties would lead it to keep gaining
market share against Fiat by then
Bitcoin had risen more than
thousand percent to over one hundred and
fifty dollars clearly a bubble as Peter
said later that year in December of that
year I got to have my first debate with
Peter Schiff on his podcast yet again I
stated that the technology was immensely
valuable and that bitcoins utility has
an unblockable global payment network
meant that it would keep growing by then
Bitcoin had risen another five hundred
percent to over eight hundred dollars
again Peter called it a bubble a beanie
baby fad a Ponzi scheme he actually said
that it was no better than Fiat fast
forward to today even after the crash
from December's frothy highs Bitcoin is
yet eight hundred percent higher still
at six thousand dollars every major
financial institution and government in
the world is studying this right now
this year's Davos may have well been
called blockchains how worried should we
be at what point at what point do I get
to call scoreboard here this isn't some
sci-fi future thing anymore crypto is
currently pulling in the global
financial system and restructuring it
through a process of free market
metamorphosis and it is about damn time
that we had free markets again look I
can sit here and tell you guys all the
cool features of Bitcoin which I have
been doing for seven years but when it
comes to the resolution being made
tonight there is really just one most
critical point to understand and that is
this Bitcoin cannot be debased it cannot
be debased and it is now competing with
the incumbent currency u.s. dollar fiat
which not only can be debased but exists
in a state of perpetual
institutionalized debasement this
dynamic will encourage a virtuous cycle
in which rational actors at the margins
decide to hold the non decaying form of
money to the exclusion of that which
decays this is the primary reason gold
itself has retained its position in
society it cannot be - based by
governments either when comparing two
potential monetary alternatives the one
which is the hardest to debase is
probably the one you should prefer other
factors being equal but here the other
factors aren't equal one of them can
also be transferred anywhere on earth
between any two people instantly at near
zero cost and can't be shut down or
censored how is that for intrinsic value
but ignore for a moment every
interesting advantage of Bitcoin ignore
the ease with which one can send it
ignore the censorship resistance
or the universality the fungibility and
the divisibility ignore the
impossibility of counterfeit true
Bitcoin surpasses US dollar Fiat in all
of these but ignore those for a moment
focus purely on the fact the
mathematical fact that Bitcoin cannot be
debased no matter how many guns a
government wields no matter how much
propaganda it spews or innocent people
in imprisons it does not matter how many
meetings the Federal Reserve holds in
its halls of chiseled marble every year
Fiat uses from the sewer of state as
consequence it has lost 98 percent of
its value in the past hundred years how
foolish does one need to be to hold it
over the next hundred compared to gold
Bitcoin provides an efficient digital
apparatus of payment and exchange that
can enable commerce rather than hinder
it but more importantly compared to fiat
the coin bestows a gift for which
humanity will grow increasingly hungry
an open honest financial system that is
under the control of no man committee or
nation bitcoin will find its way into
every tributary of economic activity and
with this gradual adoption the coin will
come to replace fiat as the preferred
money and medium of exchange for all
sovereign people on earth
[Applause]
well as I admitted before of all the
bubbles that I have not participated in
during my career the one I most regret
is Bitcoin
I mean clearly if there was ever a
bubble that was tailor-made for me that
was the one but just because the bubble
has gotten bigger and bigger and bigger
doesn't change the nature of what it is
and the fact that you are right now that
there is so much attention being paid to
Bitcoin that wasn't being paid to it
when it was three dollars a coin but it
is being paid to it now I think back in
December when it was making its peak and
the futures were debuting I was talking
on my podcast and I decided to rename
CNBC crypto news Bitcoin because that's
all they talked about it was non-stop of
course they won't have me on to
criticize it they won't have anyone on
to criticize it all I have is one person
after another talking about how great it
is and I was gonna keep going up and I
would suggest that when you have such
mainstream you know buying that you've
probably reached a peak him and I
brought my high school son here he's got
his friend here from high school and
they both own Bitcoin although my son
was smart enough to sell it he sold his
at nineteen hundred so don't clap but
his friend still has his but when the
high school kids are buying it look it's
not the bottom anymore people still
trying to tell me it's the ground floor
or buy your bitcoins now because they're
going to a million look you know they I
could just because I didn't buy them at
three bucks or 50 bucks or thousand
bucks or 5000 bucks doesn't mean I'm
gonna make the mistake and sir coming to
the greed and buying into them now
because that's how all bubbles die first
you have the skeptics you know they
don't want to buy it and then eventually
they capitulate they throw in the towel
their greed overwhelms them and they buy
in and and you make a top and the
markets gonna collapse and that's what's
going to happen I have a pretty good
track record of seeing these bubbles
whether it's in the real estate market
or the dot-com market I mean this if it
looks like a bubble quacks like a bubble
walks like a bubble it's a bubble you
talk about debasing that Bitcoin can't
be debased the whole term debasement
comes from taking a precious metal
and in coin and then putting a base
metal into it so you don't really get as
much gold as you thought you were
getting because you've got some lesser
metal instead well you can't the base
bid coin because there's nothing to
debase there's no value there to start
with it doesn't matter if you had some
other cryptocurrency because you've got
nothing and it doesn't matter you know
whether you know you don't have all the
Bitcoin that I thought I have because at
the end of the day there's there's
nothing there I don't think that the
current fiat system will withstand the
test of time I mean fiat money has been
tried and failed all throughout history
I don't think this giant experiment is
gonna succeed any better as Eric
mentioned earlier we've only been on
this Fiat system since 1971 when the
u.s. went off the gold standard and
prior to that we convinced everybody to
be on a dollar standard but the reason
the world held dollars was because the
dollar was backed by gold and not only
backed by gold but convertible on demand
into gold and so I think this experiment
is going to end it has done incredible
amounts of damage so I think it's going
away but I don't think we're going to go
to Bitcoin or any of these other fiat
crypto currencies I think we will go
back to where we were I think the dollar
will once again be backed by gold at
some point if some exchange rate you
know and maybe there will be private
companies that will compete with
governments by issuing crypto currencies
backed by something I happen to think
it's best to back them by gold but
somebody could back them by some other
commodity as long as you have money
that's backed with something of stable
reliable value that you can relate to
other goods and services then it can be
the basis of medium exchange I mean
modern technology does make it easier
today I would think that gold today with
the technology that exists is easier for
gold to function as money than at any
point in human history and that is the
real advancement that we have whether
it's blockchain or anything else it's
the ability to digitally transfer stored
gold around the world
right that's what is the evolution or
the advancement of money it's the
improvement on what works you don't need
to reinvent something that works gold
has worked as money
was first created in fact the most
prosperous period in American history
was when we were on the purest gold
standard in American history and I think
that hopefully America will reimburse
that monetary heritage once again and
hopefully the rest of the world will
also enjoy the benefits of sound money
and move off of the you know constant
booms and busts associated with fiat
money and I think it's ironic that one
of the booms and busts is in Bitcoin and
crypto currencies and I think that the
crypto bubble is going to pop before the
overall Fiat bubble pops and if anything
it actually might end up achieving the
opposite of its purpose because it
actually might succeed in doing the one
thing that you shouldn't be able to do
it'll actually succeed in making fiat
money look good thank you
thank you Peter thank you Eric for your
superb insights again the resolution
reads Bitcoin or a similar form of
cryptocurrency will eventually replace
government's fiat money governments fiat
money as the preferred medium of
exchange and so we're gonna open the
close open the final vote we all ready
to close the vote so could you bring me
the results and I will give it all right
the the resolution was again Bitcoin
will eventually replace government's
fiat money as a medium of exchange the
yes votes started 40% and rose to 55% in
the phone so yeah so us either picked up
15 points that's the number to beat
Peter did not beat that number when for
40% a little bit down to 31 so Eric you
got the 2-0 congratulations
[Applause]